Keith how are you this morning
well I'm upright did you how'd you
celebrate your birthday quietly of you
are you watching much football much
sports oh I'm wearing out the chair at
the dining room table I've been known to
sit here 12 hours looking at different
really sports television but I'll tell
you a kind of a weird thing and I don't
really know why but when I left the Rose
Bowl and oh six after the USC Texas game
and the game I thought was marred by
mistakes on all people involved ball
game what was one of the most exciting
games I've ever seen was not in fact one
of the best games I've ever seen because
there were too many mistakes made on all
parts but I came home I sat down at the
supper table and had a meal with my
bride then we leaned back and we watched
a little television went to bed and went
on into a whole new step in our lives
and I have not yet been to a football
game I'm any kind anywhere since that oh
six game that was the final broadcast
for you that was it but Vin Scully said
to me last year that he'll know when
it's time how did you know it was time
Oh even at the point where the Sun
looked funny coming up over the horizon
it became more and more difficult trying
to assume that someone was right or
wrong and it was very difficult to trace
it down chase it down and get a
declaration that you could believe in
and I got tired of trying to do that and
I figured I wasn't qualified to do what
I was trying to be and so quick
56 years is long enough yeah yeah yeah
that's a long time that's why I marvel
at what Vin's been able to do for this
amount of time and to do it with just
one team yeah you did it with one sport
yeah yeah and that's probably less
wearing than what we were trying to do
there at ABC run all over the world and
cover the things that people have never
heard of before
and if you didn't save your notes and
some producer called and said hey
tomorrow afternoon we got to do a
layover on some sports that you'd
forgotten the Juke had ever seen so that
tends to wear you down a little quicker
I think probably than the repetitive
stuff what do you miss the most oh I
miss the excitement of one team winning
in and one team losing and there have
been many moments that have long since
passed from our memories that I still
recall as being extraordinary moments in
in in the games that we play I remember
one time that that watching in a
baseball game that probably a few people
were watching but young fellah showed up
on a mound and I can't even tell you now
at this age what his name was but I
watched him strike out the entire
Cincinnati batting order and save a game
in st. Louis and I didn't think that was
possible because since it back
Cincinnati back in those days had some
real hammer throwers yeah the Big Red
Machine
hard to strike him out he did it on that
one afternoon he said Keith Jackson a
great broadcaster joining us Dan Patrick
show when you first started out you know
with having you being from Georgia
having that southern voice was that ever
an issue when it came to broadcasting on
the national level or hurt you in any
job interviews oh yeah of course it did
because I think that the people on the
other side of the table made more of it
than was
because I never did try to manufacture a
southern voice it was just what was
taught to me or what was I heard as a
little fella but over the course of that
youth somebody and and III think of many
people who might have been the source of
it was that if you're going to be in
broadcasting there is one thing that you
must never ever ever give up on you must
never stop accumulating vocabulary and
it's still true what was it about
college football that seemed to fit your
voice whether that you thought that was
the perfect fit for it but we certainly
found that it was the perfect fit for
your voice well I never thought about it
it was your voice ahead the game of
football involves every emotion that's
possible to a human being in the course
of 60 minutes I think you can probably
be touched by any emotion you can think
of a short of childbirth and we're
working on that but that's I guess my my
prime reason for it because to this very
day you can see on the playground which
one of the little fellas is suddenly
squared his shoulders and bowed his neck
and will go on and try to express
himself over the opponent and that's
that's life it's competitive
it has all of the competitive elements
of making living and raising a family
and all of that why do people still
think that you said whoa Nellie I got it
from my grandfather great-grandfather
Jefferson Davis Robert
who was not a large fellow but he was a
very good farmer and he was always
working on something with his hands and
creating things to make his life a
little easier but he had a little bit of
a temper underneath that hat that he
wore all the time and when he would get
frustrated or drop something or break
something many times I heard him say as
he had that half whistle that so many
people seem to have back in those days
where he wasn't really a whistle it was
just sort of a kind of and grandpa would
would break something and I could hear
him say oh I thought that there were
times when you people kept saying all
say well Nelly or there was one
expression that you were given credit
for that I thought you tried to distance
yourself from was there one or am I
forgetting something here yeah I thought
for some reason that you were saying you
didn't say well Nelly and then I I know
you'd say yeah different phrases but for
some reason I thought people were trying
to pin that on on you with whoa Nelly
but if it's yours then I apologize well
I didn't and also did you were you up
for doing the miracle and ice doing the
hockey broadcast during the 1980 Winter
Olympics that Al Michaels did were you
part of that decision at all yes I was
absolutely was part of it I said no and
right on the Georgia Alabama line then
we didn't have hockey down south in
those years we didn't have major league
anything down south in those years if
you remember I mean the Nashville Vols
were important to the Atlantic crackers
and the Mobil bears and
and those folks but I never had been to
I you know I I went to my first hockey
game and saw a real hockey game 2 pro
teams playing in New York City when I
had been in the Marine Corps for two and
a half years and his friend of mine who
lived in Brooklyn took me to see a
hockey game that's first one I've ever
seen I didn't know a damn thing about
hockey so I wasn't go up there and make
a full breakfast and al had done hockey
in Cincinnati and and some other places
and was well versed in it and did a fine
job yeah
what's great to catch up with you hope
many more birthdays there and we we
appreciate you taking time to join us
Keith well I wish you continued success
you've done quite well for yourself
young fella Thank You Keith thank you
thank you I appreciate that
happy birthday thank you that's Keith
Jackson 88 years of age the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience